diese mond dürfte es eigentlich nicht
geben die sprache ist vom 14 mond des
planeten neptun der winzling es 2004 in
1 hat nur einen durchmesser von etwa 34
kilometern und wurde bis zu seiner
endgültigen entdeckung vor sechs jahren
also 2013 immer wieder übersehen doch
warum existiert der trotz seiner
geringen größe dauerhaft experten und
expertinnen ist es tatsächlich gelungen
mit hilfe von neun analysetechniken
einigen rätseln zu neptuns mini und
jetzt auf die schliche zu kommen auch
den größten kriegs um science-fiction
hier gibt's täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst er nichts herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
insgesamt 14 monde des äußersten
planeten neptun unseres sonnensystems
sind uns bislang bekannt neptun selbst
wurde bereits 1846 aufricht wird und nur
drei wochen später waren sein erster
mond namens triton nach und nach wurden
dann sechs weitere monde entdeckt die
innerhalb neptuns umlaufbahn kreisen die
nasa raumsonde voyager 2 hatte sie
bereits 189 fotografiert aber auch
weiter außen gibt es monde des neptuns
und zwar sieben stück doch erst 2004 gab
es erste hinweise auf den inneren
siebten mond 2013 gelang es dann endlich
den vierzehnten mond von neptun
endgültig zu entdecken und zwar mit
hilfe des hubble-weltraumteleskops doch
selbst in diesen aufnahmen kann man
diese mond nur als einen unscharfen
punkt erkennen kein wunder denn
schließlich handelt es sich hierbei es
2004 n1 um einen echten mini mond mit
einem durchmesser von gerade einmal 34
kilometern in etwa so groß wie ultima
thule also es 2004 n1 liegt etwa 100
5400 kilometer von seinem mutterplaneten
entfernt einen umlauf braucht 23 stunden
seine runden dreht der mini mond nur
etwa 12.000 kilometer innerhalb der
umlaufbahn von proteus das ist der
zweitgrößte mond für kosmische
verhältnisse ist das wirklich eine
verschwindend geringe entfernung das war
also wirklich eine große überraschung
sagt sein entdecker mark schulter wir
hätten nicht erwartet so einen kleinen
mond so nah neben neptuns größtem innere
mond zu entdecken
lange zeit wurde der mini mond nur mit
seiner katalognummer erst 2001
bezeichnet in einer aktuellen studie in
dem
im wissenschaftsmagazin nature bekommt
aber jetzt den namen hypo camp verpasst
ein wirklich passender name der an die
griechische mythologie anknüpft konkret
nämlich anders meeresungeheuer hypo camp
das vorne ein pferde körper hat und
hinten eine fischflosse und tatsächlich
die analogie passt neptuns mini mond ist
weder fisch noch fleisch
paradoxerweise ist epo kämpfen nämlich
eigentlich zu klein um eine solch lange
zeit zu existieren schließlich könnte in
jeder größeren gestein schlag
zertrümmern und dem winzling ein ende
bereiten warum also existiert der
dennoch dauerhaft und wie ist er
überhaupt entstanden fragen die die
fachleute bis heute zuvor sehr große
rätsel gestellt hatten doch jetzt ist es
dem us forschungsteam um marc stolte vom
kalifornischen seti-institut mit hilfe
von neuen analysetechniken gelungen
endlich neue erkenntnisse zu gewinnen
hierbei handelt es sich übrigens um
genau dieselben wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler die den kleinen mond des
neptuns 2013 mit dem weltraumteleskop
hubble auch entdeckt hatten in ihrer
aktuellen studie stellen sie den
trabanten genauer vor geben ihm den
namen hip hop kemp und äußern zudem auch
vermutungen wie er entstanden sein
könnte und zwar könnte er sich demnach
aus einschlags trümmern gebildet haben
und zwar aus teilen von proteus dem
zweitgrößten neptun und wie gesagt zieht
im camp nou rund 12.000 kilometer
innerhalb von proteus seiner bahn und
dort befindet sich ein wirklich extrem
großer einschlagskrater der 1989
entdeckt worden war und fans genannt
wird dort heraus ist wohl eine große
anzahl an gestein ins all geschleudert
worden was höchstwahrscheinlich dann für
die bildung von hypo camp gesorgt hat
auf diese vermutung kommt das
forschungsteam weil das volumen des mini
mondes genau dem 2 prozent der fehlenden
materie im einschlagskrater entspricht
zudem spricht nicht nur die nähe der
beiden trabanten für diese annahme
sondern auch die extrem kleine größe von
hippo kim dazu
der verantwortliche forscher macho alter
189 dachten wir dass fahrers das ende
der geschichte sei mit den hubble daten
wissen wir jetzt dass ein kleines stück
vom proteus zurück geblieben ist und wir
gehen davon aus
dass es sich dabei um hippo kennt
handelt demnach ist es sogar möglich
dass hypo camp in den letzten vier
milliarden jahren bis zu neun mal durch
einschläge zerbröselte und sich dann
aber wieder neu aus bruchstücken
zusammengesetzt hat die neue angewandte
technik ist übrigens ziemlich clever
vereinfacht gesagt hat das
forschungsteam hier mit
unterschiedlichen belichtungen des
neptun systems herumexperimentiert acht
aufeinander folgende fünfminütige
belichtung wurden quasi übereinander
gestapelt und entsprechend angeordnet so
dass die umlauf bewegung des mondes
einer genauen analyse nicht im weg
standen so wurden acht einzelaufnahmen
zu einer 40 minuten langen
gesamtaufnahme experten und expertinnen
sind optimistisch dass diese technik
weitere überraschende entdeckung möglich
macht wie beispielsweise andere kleine
monde die um riesige planeten kreisen
wie ist der mond also der ert wohnt
entstanden auch eine ziemlich
spektakuläre geschichte hier
draufklicken dafür anschauen und astor
comics tv abonnieren würde ich mal sagen
bis dann bleibt dran